اليوم كان نتيجه الزلزال الجديد تشقق في
بعض المنازل نتيجه
ان التاثير كان في الساحل اكثر من مناطق
اخرى في حاله تساقطت الشماليه مباني او
انهارت بشكل جزئي في عده احياء من حلب
ولكن لم يكن داخلها اي مواطن وهذا شيء كان
جنبنا سقوط مفيد من الضحايا ولكن مع الاسف
حالات التي كانت اكبر حتى في ادلب كان
هناك رمي من يعني البعض يقرب القفز من
الشرفات المنازل نتيجه الخوف البعض نتيجه
تدافع ايضا سقطت عليه احجره حجاره
بالمباني التي تهدمت اي ان الحالات هي
اكثر من هذه الارقام التي تحدثنا منها
عليها هناك في بعض المناطق لم نستطيع
الوصول اليها حقيقه الامر الغريب استاذ
رامي اننا بيتنا نسجل قتلى جراء الهلع
والخوف من الزلزال يعني هذا شيء يعني لا
اعلم كيف يمكن ان نصفه